et spyker ont appris qu'elle faisait
officiellement une grande tournée
britannique le groupe meetic va donc se
reformer et sans victoria beckham est en
route explique tout parce qu'elle va
quand même prendre de lausanne
c'est officiel les spice girls ont dit
oui oui pour un come-back une tournée
spéciale et un retour sous les
projecteurs attendu par des centaines de
milliers de fans à travers le monde qui
ne se sont toujours pas remis de la
rupture du groupe en 2001 d'espacé plus
de 100 millions de disques vendus des
tournées gigantesques des milliers de
produits dérivés et des millions de vues
pour leur clip dont le premier single i
wanna be
[Musique]
un retour très attendu par les
nostalgiques des années 90 qui pourront
admirer une partie du groupe sur scène
car victoria beckham styliste à succès
et femme du footballeur anglais ne fera
pas partie de l'aventuré
elle a tout de même souhaité bonne
chance à ses anciennes camarades sur
instagram je leur souhaite autant
d'amour pour leur tournée que celui que
j'ai reçu à l'époque pour rappel en 2012
les spice girls avait déjà réalisé un
come back réussi avec un show mémorable
aux jo de londres rendez vous le 1er
juin 2019 pour le tout premier concert
de leur tournée exceptionnelle de six
dates pour voir les spice girls une
toute dernière fois avant très
certainement la prochaine tournée come
back dans dix ans beckham a réagi je
vous le dis à la suite de voilà du
retour des espagnols
aujourd'hui est un jour spécial pour les
filles qui ont annoncé leur première
tournée depuis notre spectacle en 2012
je n'y participerai pas mais le groupe
des spice girls mort on voit une période
très importante de ma vie et je souhaite
beaucoup d'amour et de fun à ces quatre
chanteuses qui partiront en tournée
l'année prochaine bon allez loin
derrière leur dicte orcières touchera
quand même des recettes sur la tournée
est ce que les bénéfices engendrés par
les quatre spice girl lui reviendront de
droits à hauteur de 20%
elle fait rien ne change pas le va
toucher ben c'est comme kanye ce soir
avec vous
les palaces à y aller avec david beckham
tout ça frère c est alors qu al ahly
ça m'énerve victoria tu me fais de la
peine
une autre fille de hockey lui ont fait
écoute tu viennes de la chute des
copines
ok c'est celle qui ont le moins réussi
financièrement tu as également stéphane
pour arriver ça en plus on va me payer
une blinde pour ce concert tu aurais pu
abaisser un peu dans un hologramme alors
et feront un tube my lover km il bat
mike h hockey s'est passé l'an dernier
[Applaudissements]
et vous savez que là j'ai voulu prendre
place avec des copains prenez un
week-end à wembley
vous n'y allez pas les spice girls way
rally nerfs c'est d'essayer pc j'aime
bien comme ça t'en remercie dangereuse
non non non je vous emmènerai keim non
merci de passer une nuit à londres
bon bref la place la moins chère la
moins chère c'est 300 l arbre notre os x
300 $ dans la fosse tu vois rien tu es
plus dans l'escarcelle alors no be my
lover's assez venir avec moi trois cent
300 $ dans la fosse alors dollars est
déjà comme cela ça les dents à ce prix
là je prends 4 s pour bah oui il valoir
moi je l ai même pris moi prendre
jusqu'à deux mois ce qui est paradoxal
c'est qu'on connaisse venir vous
ressemblez à victoria beckham bord m'a
dit ça fait mais c'est vrai vous avez la
même coiffure que du corps et âme
qu'avez-vous david eux n'ont pas
d'avenir à travers ses cannes
[Applaudissements]
c'est david beckham est paradoxal c'est
qu'on se souvient sur marjah mais en
fait c'était le maillon faible pendant
les heures des spice gars ça veut dire
que c'est la seule par exemple qui ne
chante pas en solo dans le tube wannabe
et elle a raconté que le producteur
parfois coupé son micro pour qu'on
entende mieux choix les autres parce que
c'était pas terrible sur trois est ça la
vrai que si souvent le be my love et
bien que six dates bébé sachez le
merci à lui il va gagner à lui faction
il va être chaud il va la voir l'espace
go